uh so much of course to be discussed uh
by those nato uh member leaders today i
guess one of the key ones will be
exactly how to interpret article five
the idea that an attack on one is an
attack on all uh if things continue as
they are focused just in ukraine or if
they escalate going into other countries
or perhaps more likely a change of the
tactics and weaponry that russia is
using in your ukraine what what do you
think nato members uh take on that will
be today
well i think it's essential for
deterrence that there is a certain
ambiguity about
the interpretation of article five this
is also reason why i
think nato leaders should not exclude
this or that action
in my opinion they have been too eager
to exclude this or that
in the event of russian
attacks
and chains of strategies
we are undermining our own deterrence if
we exclude
actions it
provides a room maneuver for putin so
that would be my main advice don't
exclude any action
and if there's no formal announcements
on that point to maintain flexibility mr
mr rasmussen today what do you think
internally they will be saying what
would be a possible trigger for military
action from nato would it be the use of
chemical weapons by russia in ukraine
there are certainly red lines the use of
chemical weapons biological weapon not
to speak about nuclear weapons of course
but also when it comes to the definition
of red lines i think we shouldn't be too
clear because that could tempt mr putin
to really test
our resolve
i think
an important decision today would be
to pave the way for a permanent
stationing of nato troops in eastern
allied countries the baltic states
poland and romania to protect nato
against any russian attack
how much stronger are nato forces or
potentially stronger if those types of
steps are taken
than russian forces in the eventuality
the hypothetical situation where no
nuclear weapons were used just fights
uh military engagements on the ground in
ukraine would nato forces overwhelm
russian forces with ease
i think we
well first of all
nato forces are much more efficient much
stronger
than the russian army we have really
seen the russians fail in their attempts
to carry out a blitz creek
in ukraine we have overestimated the
strength of the russian forces so i have
no doubt that if we deploy a substantial
number of nato troops in eastern allied
countries
that would deter
russia but on the other hand i think we
will need around 100
000 troops permanently stationed
or on a regular rotational basin
basis
stationed in eastern
countries
and of course uh mr rasmussen you you
have a a greater insight than any of us
on
how likely uh the member states are to
take that step do you think there is
sufficient urgency and unity among nato
members to take it today
yeah i think in principle they will
agree uh to reinforce their total
defense uh in in the east
but equally important will be
the the subsequent eu summit today
because we have to stop the financing of
putin's war
that could be done if we
immediately stop all imports of oil and
gas from russia and that would take an
eu decision
we of course got the focus on president
biden this particular week mr rasmussen
but if we were to step back and consider
the the four presidents of the united
states that have been in power during
president putin's tenure leading leading
russia
do any of them stand out to you to
having enabled putin's overreach more
than the others
i i think putin has changed as a person
when i first met putin in 2002 uh bush
was the president in the united states
and actually bush and putin had a very
good relationship and if you look back
putin was very pro-western at that time
then he changed his attitude around i
would say 2000 2007 he he turned
anti-western
then president obama took over and he
tried a reset in our relationship
with
russia i supported that i think we
should reach out to russia and give give
them a chance
then of course president trump was a
special
example
i think he did a lot of harm
to nato undermining our credibility
up with putin etc and now we have biden
who is a he's a very committed
internationalist he has really been a
driving force in creating western unity
i appreciate that
you mentioned there president putin's
pivot or or certainly change in tone uh
towards the west uh towards the back
half of the first decade of this century
one wonders whether nato expansion
contributed to that rightly or wrongly
that the spin he might have
applied to what is otherwise a defensive
organization back home in in russia uh
particularly in 2004 seven nations
joined i i bring it up because of course
many people talking today about whether
his invasion of ukraine might lead to
countries like finland or sweden to now
join nato do you think that that's now
likely and would that potentially make
putin's aversion to the west worse
i hope finland and sweden would join
nato and i think the two countries in
their self-interest should use the
current window opportunity to apply for
membership because putin is preoccupied
elsewhere he can't do anything and it
would be a defeat
for putin to see finland and sweden
join nato but in general i would say
russia is not a victim
nato has
the whole way through being
a defensive alliance we are not
threatening russia we have reached out
to russia on several occasions
um so we did the right thing
at the right moment taking on board
former communist states in eastern
europe and thanks to the decisions
in 2002 2004 they are now well protected
by nato's article iv
think about the situation now if we
hadn't taken that decision
back then
the baltic states would now be under
threat
one final question for me mr rasmussen
just to sum things up what would you
like to see nato leaders announce today
that would turn the tide in in this war
without creating greater aggression
yeah first of all
permanent stationing in in the east but
i think we should cut off
all imports of oil and gas each and
every day
we
pour money into putin's coffers by
purchasing
oil and gas at very high prices
we have to put an end to this
devastating war and do it quickly it
will come at a price but the price if
the wall is dragging on would be much
higher